What would happen if somebody just handed you
three strange magic cards and asked you to
build a commander deck around them? Could you do
it? Recently I asked my patrons what cards they
wanted to see me play in a deck, and then I ran a
poll to decide the three I’d be building with. The
results? The Sibsig Ceremony, Aether Vial, and
Birthing Ritual. This is actually not the worst
set of cards I could have gotten handed to me.
The Sibsig Ceremony was the card that by far the
most people most wanted to see, and this Tarkir:
Dragonstorm enchantment makes all of our creatures
cost two colorless less but destroys them when
they enter if we cast them, replacing them with
a zombie. This is definitely a big downside, but
the silver lining here is that the other two cards
offer ways to get creatures into play without
casting them. Birthing Ritual is a two mana
enchantment that offers a sort of limited birthing
pod effect, letting us look at the top 7 cards
of our library on each end step and sacrifice a
creature to replace it with one from those cards.
Aether Vial is a much older card, a one mana
artifact that can gain a counter on our upkeep
and which taps to put a creature with mana value
equal to the number of counters on it into play.
So, where to start here? For one,
we’re in at least Golgari colors,
and with a triple black on The Sibsig Ceremony
we’re gonna be hard-pressed to push too far beyond
that without some Urborg-oriented assistance.
All three of these cards care about creatures,
and some of them care about creatures kind
of a lot. Birthing Ritual is probably the
lowest-commitment card here—it has a low mana
cost, relatively flexible criteria for podding
things, and you get to see all your options before
sacrificing. Really the only thing this needs to
work well is a moderately large creature count,
though it can also help to have a decent spread
between mana values to allow stairstepping up in
mana costs. Speaking of which, let’s talk about
Aether Vial. It’s a card traditionally played in
heavily-creature-based decks with relatively low
average mana values—typically you drop it
early, get it up to two or three counters,
and then pop out extra dudes at instant speed for
the rest of the game. This makes sense in a fast
60 card deck, but what about in an EDH deck? The
effect of deploying creatures more rapidly isn’t
such a guaranteed benefit in the slower, typically
higher-curved EDH format. The card also doesn’t do
anything immediately after played, which certainly
doesn’t spell success for a card in EDH, but maybe
there’s a niche for it—it’s still a low-cost
card, and the instant speed might be useful in
some instances. Like Birthing Ritual, this card
is going to be looking for a high creature count
to be useful, and preferably a relatively low
average mana cost among those creatures so that
the card is actually able to feel impactful in
the first couple turns after it’s been played.
The most challenging thing here is definitely
The Sibsig Ceremony, and that’s because it
comes with a fat downside—your creatures
literally get destroyed as soon as they
enter. Among the five commanders this sees
significant play in, none include green,
so we’re gonna have to get creative here. One of
the issues in commander selection is that even if
a commander works well once it’s on the board with
Sibsig in play, you’re constrained to playing the
commander before the enchantment, and if your
commander ever gets removed Sibsig is going
to make it tricky to get it back onto the board.
This isn’t to say there are no solutions to this,
though. Indestructible works since Sibsig
destroys the creatures rather than making
you sacrifice them, and this leaves a handful
of options such as Sapling of Colfenor, Kotis,
most Gods, and any partner pair that includes
Anara. There are also other commanders that
can be made to have Indestructible if you
build them right—the Mimeoplasm can copy a
creature with indestructible, and Indoraptor
will likewise be indestructible if you have
an indestructible creature to discard. You
could also run some cards in the 99 that
regenerate a creature or return it to play
when it dies, pull a Scam on your opponents.
But what about the final option, the forbidden
option—what if your commander wants to die?
This brings me to my choice of champion—Iname
as One. This is a 12 mana 8/8 that, if played
from hand, tutors out a spirit into play when it
enters, and recurs a spirit to play when it dies.
But what sorts of spirits might you want to tutor
and recur? Well, how about Iname and Iname? Here’s
the default plan when we cast our commander from
hand with The Sibsig Ceremony in play: Iname as
One enters. Two triggers go on the stack, one to
destroy it, and the other to tutor out a spirit.
We choose to resolve the spirit-searching first,
and tutor out Iname, Death Aspect. When this card
enters, it searches our library for any number of
spirits and puts them into our graveyard. We put
whichever spirits we like into our graveyard,
with one of them being Iname, Life Aspect. Now
the Sibsig trigger on Iname as One resolves and
it dies, creating a zombie, and then its death
trigger happens, putting Iname, Life Aspect back
into play. Now what happens from here? Honestly,
could be a lot of things, but ideally if
Life Aspect is indeed your choice to recur,
you’ve got some way or other to sacrifice
it. One of these would be Birthing Ritual,
but there are several others. Illuminor
Szeras can sacrifice this Iname for mana,
Greater Good can draw us some cards,
He Who Hungers can force an opponent
to discard something, and so on, ten cards in
total. This might seem like a lot of sacrifice
just to enable one single element of our plan,
but something I noticed early on in building is
that sacrifice outlets are actually pretty
sweet with The Sibsig Ceremony in general,
because it destroys the creatures. So you’ve got
all these creatures that are going to die anyway,
and you may as well sacrifice them. There are
even some that care about power or mana value,
and for those, sacrificing Iname as One itself can
be a fantastic power burst in an already big turn.
In some sense this gameplan might seem like
a combo, but in truth, having as many of its
spirits in hand as it wants does not win the
game. It certainly makes it easier, and will
lead to rapid victory sometimes with the right
prerequisites, but I didn’t feel like hammering
this deck’s commander plan into a consistent win,
for reasons that may become clear a bit later. No,
instead this deck is a patchwork of different
payoffs and wincons that align with the central
pillars of this deck that we’ve laid out.
First off, there’s a perfectly adequate
spirits midrange plan. A couple Myojin exist
as top-end indestructible threats, one of which
being Myojin of Life’s Web that can dump a loaded
hand onto the board in short order. There are also
several other spirits with effects that happen
when spirit or arcane cards are played—Infernal
Kirin strips out opposing hands, Kodama of the
South Tree pumps up our board, zombies included,
and Kodama of the East Tree can allow for quicker
deployment of spirits. Getting these out safely
with The Sibsig Ceremony in play can be tricky,
but there are a few options. One would be to
regenerate a creature with Accursed Duneyard,
and another would be to use the front side of
Malakir Rebirth or Revitalizing Repast to keep
the creature in question alive. The final option
is Aether Vial—though this deck doesn’t fit the
conventional mana curve of an Aether Vial deck,
it is at least somewhat predictable in what
spirits it will have available, and can plan
ahead to have a certain number of counters for a
pivotal turn based on what seems like it’ll be the
best play. The final option for a wincon here is
the lands package, and this actually came up about
quite organically. First, a number of specific
lands really help out with our gameplan—Urborg
for casting The Sibsig Ceremony, Reliquary
Tower for holding a fat hand of spirits,
Accursed Duneyard for getting around The Sibsig
Ceremony, Command Beacon for getting Iname into
hand, and a few second-tier lands as well. In
addition, a number of cards that naturally fit
into the deck just inherently work well with
a lands package—Kura is a classic lands card,
Wight of the Reliquary is a lovely sac ability
zombie, and Spirit of the Aldergard is a
friendly bear who can find us a Dark Depths.
So herein lies the final wincon—Field of the
Dead can get us even more zombies, Dark
Depths can do its dark and depthy things,
and a couple manlands can swing real big
as a result of this deck’s strange quirks.
So that’s how this deck tries to run to the finish
line, but it’d be a little unfair for me to not
talk about the setup steps. Like sure, for some
decks you can start the gameplan at casting the
commander, but getting to that point is in this
case a bit of a herculean task. The card is 12
mana, and relevantly we need to get it into our
hand before playing it—the ETB trigger doesn’t
happen if we cast it from the command zone. So
let’s start there. In this deck there are four
cards that allow getting our commander into
the command zone—Campfire, Netherborn Alter,
Road of Return, and Command Beacon—and getting
one of these will naturally be a requirement for
any sort of commander based gameplay, unless we’re
real down bad for a recursion spell. Next up, the
12 mana part—that’s a lot of mana, but thankfully
there’s a decent amount of high caliber ramp that
slots nicely into this deck. There are several
ramp sources that are spirits as well, and these
include a handful of spirit-or-arcane-effect
cards from original Kamigawa, as well as
Crypt Ghast, which is a fantastic card if
we can get Urborg into play. Joining these
is Illuminor Szeras and Soldevi Adnate, which
we’d prefer to use on one of the Inames to get
a massive surge of mana, but these can also help
build up to a commander cast as well in a pinch.
Finally there are a few other ramp cards that just
happen to be lovely in this particular deck, with
those including Enduring Vitality, Seance Board,
and the aforementioned Wight of the Reliquary.
Joining these is a decent draw suite as well—14
cards if I include Birthing Ritual among them,
which I am choosing to do, and if you have issues
with that I recommend you leave a comment telling
me all about it. Many of these are quite
large scale draw, drawing potentially five
or more cards given average circumstances, and
my hope is that pairing this with the similarly
potent ramp suite should allow the deck to
consistently climb in mana and get where it
needs to go. I’m also running four tutors to
find The Sibsig Ceremony or other key pieces,
which isn’t a massive number but should be enough
with the other draw present. In the ideal world
I’d love to go a little bit higher with each of
these values, but one thing this deck doesn’t
have a lot of is extra space to work with. I’m
already spending a bunch of slots just making
my questionable commander even functional, and
adding more draw and ramp would inevitably end
up eating into something else. My amount of
interaction is already lower than I’d like,
so the only way to make more space would be to
cut spirits, which would weaken my spirit synergy
cards and give me fewer options once I’m doing
Iname-oriented things. Ultimately, the version
of the list I have right now seems decently enough
balanced between its different goals—able to play
as a sort of aristocrats-y spirit midrange deck,
but also able to make some big plays with its
commander once a handful of different conditions
are met. It could be cool to do a variant on this
deck that emphasizes a different part of the
gameplan more heavily, but with this deck I
think I’ve constructed a pretty reasonable,
middle of the road approach. However, this
process left me wondering what else could be done
with these three cards I’d built a deck around.
So, I challenged a few other content creators to
make a deck with the same prompt,
and they rose to the challenge.
The Trinket Mage made a Codie, Vociferous Codex
donate deck, where the goal is to donate a pesky
permanents to opponents such as The Sibsig
Ceremony, Steel Golem, or even Codie itself.
There’s also some amount of permanent swapping,
theft, and threaten effects here, and Birthing
Ritual exists to sacrifice a threatened creature
before it could return to its owner’s control.
3/3 Elk made a Bhaal, Lord of Murder counter
manipulation and graveyard nonsense deck. Birthing
Ritual is great all around in this sort of
shell, Aether Vial can get combo pieces deployed
for explosive turns, and The Sibsig Ceremony is
used alongside cheap colorless creatures to fuel
Evolution Witness creature-looping combos. This
is a different approach than I took, and there’s
less broad synergy with The Sibsig Ceremony but
much more explosive combo potential with it.
Quips&Guac also picked out a Forgotten Realms
god—Myrkul, Lord of Bones. This card is pretty
neat with Sibsig Ceremony because when it
destroys your creatures, they simply come back
as enchantments. Myrkul also has an indestructible
clause, so there’s a decent chance of being able
to get it back out at some point if it gets
deleted with The Sibsig Ceremony on board,
and this deck packs a whole lot of ramp to
pay for expensive plays with its commander.
Arcosa built a Tayam combo deck.
Aether Vial and Birthing Ritual
are solid here since a large portion
of the deck is 1-3 mana creatures,
and The Sibsig Ceremony helps out with
multiple of the deck’s combo lines.
Gravecrawler definitely stands out as a card that
The Sibsig Ceremony really works well alongside,
since it provides a zombie and doubles the
amount of potential sac triggers per cast.
Blood Artist built a Sultai midrange
deck around Teval, the Balanced Scale.
This is a heavily creature-based deck to
support Birthing Ritual and Aether Vial,
and we can see a number of cool Sibsig
Ceremony interactions here—lots of sac outlets,
lots of ETBs and death abilities, a ton of
recursion for looping ETB and death abilities,
and a number of leaving-graveyard payoffs
for generating value in the process.
Thanks to these five for taking a crack at this,
I love all the cool ideas here. And honestly,
I’m sure there are plenty of
other neat ideas out there too,
let me know in the comments if you have
any ideas. I do actually read them,
and I love hearing all sorts of
creative thoughts from people.
With that said, thanks for watching, and
thanks to Archidekt for supporting the channel.
I’m always so glad to be an Archidekt user when
I’m building highly conceptual decks like this
due to all of its great features for analyzing
what I’m building. With a 2 second little search,
I can isolate the spirits with the word
“die” in their text on my screen and
look at just those cards to see what’s
there, both in my mainboard and in my
maybeboard. A link to this deck is down in the
description. I also want to thank my Patrons,
some of whom are on screen now. If you
want to support what I do on this channel,
a link to my Patreon is in the description.
Finally, I was on an episode of Extra Turns that
recently released, and if you want to check that
out, that’s also going to be in the description.